In Israel last week, Eli Albag wanted to do something about his daughter, Liri, who had been captured by Hamas a year ago when she was 18 and is still a hostage somewhere in Gaza. And so he took a bullhorn and went to stand outside an event that was being held by the prime minister's political party, Likud. Basically, he wanted the people running the country to make some kind of deal with Hamas and bring his daughter home.
上周在以色列，Eli Albag 想为他的女儿 Liri 做点什么。Liri 一年前被哈马斯绑架时才 18 岁，至今仍被关押在加沙的某个地方。于是，他拿着扩音器来到总理所在政党利库德集团举办的一场活动外。基本上，他希望那些掌权者能与哈马斯达成某种协议，带他的女儿回家。
And so, OK, he's standing there with his bullhorn, this grieving, worried parent, who doesn't know if he's ever going to see his child again. And someone throws an egg at him, and another egg. Somebody yells and calls him a cancer on Israel. Somebody else accuses him of being funded by Yahya Sinwar, the head of Hamas.
好吧，他站在那儿拿着扩音器，这位悲伤、忧心忡忡的父亲不知道自己是否还能再见到孩子。有人向他扔了一个鸡蛋，又扔了一个。有人对他大喊大叫，称他是以色列的毒瘤。还有人指责他拿了哈马斯领导人叶海亚·辛瓦尔的钱。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
This is not unusual in Israel. The country is bitterly divided between people like these hostage families, who are saying stop the fighting, make a deal with Hamas, bring home the hostages, and on the other side, the prime minister's supporters and his coalition, people running the government, who want to press on with the war and get to a more complete victory over Hamas.
在以色列，这并不罕见。这个国家的人民严重分裂，一边是像这些人质家庭一样的人，他们呼吁停止战斗、与哈马斯达成协议、接回人质；另一边则是总理的支持者及其联盟，那些掌管政府的人，他们希望继续战争，直到彻底战胜哈马斯。
I have an Israeli friend who said to me that this war is different from ones in the past in Israel, because in the past, he said, once the war started, everybody united. This time, it's driven people further apart, to the point where even these anguished families, who you'd think would have universal sympathy in a country at war, are the target of all kinds of hate.
我有一位以色列朋友告诉我，这场战争与以色列过去的战争不同，因为他说，在过去，一旦战争开始，每个人都会团结一致。而这一次，它让人们更加疏离，以至于这些痛苦的家庭——你本以为在战争中的国家会获得普遍同情——却成了各种仇恨的目标。
Some other examples-- a real estate mogul, who's also a big Likud supporter, writes tweets that call for the death of the mother of one of the hostages. Or here's a video that was posted online of an Israeli right-winger on a motorcycle, who pulls over next to a group of hostage families and tells them, "You're going to be murdered. I'm going to murder you. Mark my words."
其他一些例子——一位房地产大亨，同时也是利库德集团的铁杆支持者，写推文呼吁让一名人质的母亲去死。或者网上流传的一段视频，一名以色列右翼人士骑着摩托车停在一个人质家属群体旁，对他们说：“你们会被杀的。我要杀了你们。记住我的话。”
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
So in Israel, supporting the hostages for so many people has come to mean that you oppose the Israeli government and the way that they're conducting the war, and you want a ceasefire and a deal with Hamas. I think here in the United States, we have a different picture of the hostages and what they stand for.
因此，在以色列，对许多人来说，支持人质已经意味着你反对以色列政府及其进行战争的方式，你想要停火并与哈马斯达成协议。我认为在美国，我们对人质及其代表的意义有不同的看法。
Here, I think there's this feeling that if you support the hostages, you support the war, and the current Israeli government, and the way it's conducted that war, with all the bombings and death. The hostages are a symbol, but a symbol that means different things to different people in the US and Israel.
在这里，我觉得有一种感觉，即如果你支持人质，你就是支持战争，支持当前的以色列政府，以及它进行那场战争的方式——包括所有的轰炸和死亡。人质是一个象征，但在美国和以色列，这个象征对不同的人有着不同的含义。
It's been a year since the hostages were taken. The current conflict with Hamas began last October 7 with the killing of 1,200 people and the kidnapping of 251 others. So much has happened since then, of course. Israel killed over 40,000 Palestinians. 90% of the population, almost 2 million Palestinians, have been displaced from their homes.
人质被绑架已经一年了。目前的冲突始于去年 10 月 7 日，当时哈马斯杀害了 1200 人，绑架了 251 人。当然，从那以后发生了很多事情。以色列杀害了超过 4 万名巴勒斯坦人。90% 的人口，近 200 万巴勒斯坦人被迫流离失所。
This past week, Israel expanded the war to Lebanon with a ground invasion. Iran sent missiles in response, and the White House has been scrambling to try to stop a full-out regional war. At this point, this war is about so many other things than the hostages.
过去一周，以色列将战争扩大到黎巴嫩，发动了地面入侵。伊朗对此做出了导弹回应，白宫正忙于阻止一场全面的地区战争。在这一点上，这场战争涉及的不仅仅是人质问题。
But those 251 people, 117 of them released or rescued, 70 dead, and 64 who are presumed alive and in captivity, are still this symbol. They're on posters that people put up and other people tear down. They're on Bring Them Home bracelets. But they're also people, each having their own personal and specific experience of this war, an experience that politics flattens and wipes away.
但那 251 人中，117 人获释或获救，70 人死亡，64 人被认为还活着并在被囚禁中，他们依然是这个象征。他们出现在人们张贴的海报上，又被其他人撕掉。他们出现在“带他们回家”的手环上。但他们也是活生生的人，每个人对这场战争都有自己个人和具体的经历，而政治抹平并消除了这种经历。
Just two weeks after the Hamas attack, very early on, an 85-year-old hostage named Yocheved Lifshitz was released and sent home. And Israelis were pretty excited. They did a press conference from the hospital. She was put on live TV in a wheelchair. Her daughter helped her hear the questions and give answers. Somebody asked, when Hamas released you, why did you shake the Hamas guy's hand? Her reply--
就在哈马斯袭击发生两周后，非常早期，一位名叫 Yocheved Lifshitz 的 85 岁人质获释并被送回家。以色列人感到非常兴奋。他们在医院举行了新闻发布会。她坐着轮椅出现在电视直播中。她的女儿帮她听清问题并回答。有人问，哈马斯释放你时，为什么要和那个哈马斯成员握手？她的回答是——
Because they treated us very nicely. My mom is saying that they were very delicate and gentle with them and took care of all their needs.
因为他们对待我们非常友好。我妈妈说，他们对他们非常细心和温柔，照顾了他们的所有需求。
Television commentators and newspaper columnists jumped in, calling this press conference a disaster, a propaganda win for Hamas, an embarrassment for the hospital. Mind you, Lifshitz also said a lot of awful things about Hamas in her abduction-- attackers running rampant, beating people young and old. They hit her in the ribs with a wooden pole.
电视评论员和报纸专栏作家纷纷加入，称这次新闻发布会是一场灾难，是哈马斯的宣传胜利，是医院的尴尬。请注意，Lifshitz 也说了许多关于哈马斯绑架她时的可怕事情——袭击者横行霸道，殴打年轻人和老人。他们用木棍打她的肋骨。
But the story that came out of the press conference was that she said something nice about Hamas. Within a month, the hospital's spokesman who organized the press conference was out of the job. There are certain things that Israelis just did not want to hear right then.
但新闻发布会传出的故事是她说了哈马斯的好话。不到一个月，组织新闻发布会的医院发言人就被解雇了。有些事情以色列人当时就是不想听。
Here at our program, throughout this year, we've tried to document what this war has been for Palestinians and also for Israelis. And this week, a year after those people became hostages, we thought it might be a good time to hear about their actual lived experiences, all the complicated parts that don't fit neatly into some symbolic picture of them.
在我们节目里，在这一整年里，我们试图记录这场战争对巴勒斯坦人以及以色列人意味着什么。本周，在这些人成为人质一年后，我们认为这是一个了解他们真实生活经历的好时机，包括所有那些无法整齐地塞入某种象征性图景中的复杂部分。
There are these long interviews that an Israeli journalist, Lee Naim, has been doing with hostages who've been released on a daily news podcast called Echad Bayom-- One a Day. In these interviews, you get to hear them just talking at length. They're not a sound bite, not an image on a poster. You hear what really happened, the complexity of what they went through and what they saw and felt.
以色列记者 Lee Naim 在名为《Echad Bayom》（一天一个）的每日新闻播客中，一直在采访获释的人质。在这些采访中，你可以听到他们长篇大论地讲述。他们不是一段声音片段，不是海报上的图像。你听到了真正发生了什么，他们所经历、所见、所感的复杂性。
One of the things that's especially interesting, I think, to hear is the hostages' stories about their interactions with the people holding them captive, who, I have to say, they come across with way more dimension than I might have guessed.
我觉得特别有趣的一点是，听人质讲述他们与看守者的互动，我必须说，这些看守者表现出的维度比我猜测的要多得多。
So, most of this hour, we're going to be hearing from one of the Echad Bayom interviewees, a woman named Chen Almog-Goldstein. And then when we get to the second half of the show, we're going to hear from a few of the other hostages who were interviewed. I hope you stick around. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以，在这一个小时的大部分时间里，我们将听到其中一位《Echad Bayom》采访对象的话，她叫 Chen Almog-Goldstein。然后在节目的后半部分，我们将听到其他几位受访人质的声音。希望你能留下来。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，《这是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是 Ira Glass。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Part one, The Abduction. Just a heads up-- if you're listening with kids, some of this gets intense. So, Chen Almog-Goldstein lived in a kibbutz called Kfar Aza, about two miles from the Gaza border, with her husband, Nadav, and their four children. She and Nadav met in junior high school. She worked as a social worker for a while but then focused on raising her kids.
这里是《这是美国生活》。第一部分：绑架。提前提醒一下——如果你和孩子们一起听，其中一些内容会很激烈。Chen Almog-Goldstein 住在距离加沙边境约两英里的 Kfar Aza 基布兹（集体农场），和她的丈夫 Nadav 以及四个孩子住在一起。她和 Nadav 在初中相识。她做过一段时间社会工作者，后来专注于抚养孩子。
The morning of October 7, sirens went off, and they went to the safe room in their house. One of the things that a lot of people talk about in these interviews is how mystified they were that the army did not show up. For many Israelis, that is the second astonishing thing that happened that morning, that the military forces Israelis trust to keep them safe didn't arrive for over eight hours for reasons that still haven't been formally investigated.
10 月 7 日清晨，警报响起，他们进入了家里的安全屋。在这些采访中，许多人谈论的一件事是，他们对军队没有出现感到非常困惑。对许多以色列人来说，那天早上发生的第二件令人震惊的事是，那些以色列人信任保护他们安全的军事力量在超过八个小时的时间里都没有到达，其原因至今尚未经过正式调查。
Chen's family stayed in the safe room for five hours. Then, men entered the house, reached where they were, shot her husband, Nadav, in the chest, she says, right in front of them. Soon after that, they shot her oldest daughter, Yam, in the face. Yam was 20 and home on leave from her mandatory military service. Chen says the last time she saw Yam, she was flailing on the floor.
Chen 的家人在安全屋待了五个小时。然后，男人们进入房子，到达他们所在的地方，她说，当着他们的面朝她丈夫 Nadav 的胸部开了枪。在那之后不久，他们又朝她的大女儿 Yam 的脸上开了枪。Yam 20 岁，正在休探亲假，服强制兵役。Chen 说她最后一次见到 Yam 时，她正倒在地上挣扎。
Then Chen and her three other children were led outside. There was her 17-year-old daughter, Agam, and also her two sons, who were younger, 11 and 9.
然后 Chen 和她的三个孩子被带到外面。那是她 17 岁的女儿 Agam，还有她的两个儿子，他们年纪更小，分别是 11 岁和 9 岁。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
They led us to Nadav's car, first to Nadav's car and then to my car. They tried to start Nadav's car, but his car, when it's starting, it's very quiet. If you don't know the car, you probably wouldn't understand. So they probably thought, it's not working. And they brought the keys to my car, and we got into my car.
他们把我们带到 Nadav 的车上，先是 Nadav 的车，然后是我的车。他们试图启动 Nadav 的车，但他的车启动时非常安静。如果你不熟悉这辆车，你可能不会明白。所以他们可能认为车坏了。然后他们拿了我的车钥匙，我们就上了我的车。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And I'm looking to the bushes, still hoping that maybe someone will signal to me with their finger. Maybe I tell the kids to escape. But on the other hand, it was dangerous. I remember realizing this is very crucial, what I decide right now. I was afraid. They had us now.
我看向灌木丛，仍然希望也许有人能用手指给我示意。也许我能告诉孩子们逃跑。但另一方面，这太危险了。我记得意识到我现在做的决定至关重要。我很害怕。他们现在控制了我们。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I remember the kids' faces on the way to Gaza, very deep, terrified looks at me. I remember they asked me what happened to my lips, the boys. My lips were probably white. I was shocked. I was completely shocked.
我记得去加沙路上的孩子们脸上，那是非常深沉、惊恐地看着我的表情。我记得男孩们问我嘴唇怎么了。我的嘴唇可能是白色的。我很震惊。我完全震惊了。
And I'm in the car with the kids on the way to Gaza. And I need to understand and figure out that-- it was really important for me to tell the kids first that Yam is not with us anymore, and Nadav probably isn't as well.
我和孩子们在去加沙的车上。我需要理解并弄清楚——对我来说，最重要的是先告诉孩子们 Yam 不再和我们在一起了，Nadav 可能也不在了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Do the terrorists say anything?
[非英语演讲] 恐怖分子说什么了吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
They're happy. They're very happy. I remember the driver and the guy next to him, they're filming us. I remember we were putting our heads down, Agam and me. Then they stopped near the fence. It was their fence already because it was after some drive through the fields. And they piled dead bodies on my car. I remember Agam telling the boys to look away.
他们很高兴。他们非常高兴。我记得司机和旁边那个人在拍我们。我记得我和 Agam 把头低下来。然后他们在栅栏附近停了下来。那是他们的栅栏了，因为那是经过田野开了很久之后的车程。他们把尸体堆在我的车上。我记得 Agam 告诉男孩们不要看。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And after seven minutes, we're in Gaza. It's unbearable how easy it was and how fast. I mean, first of all, we were in shock. I was in shock.
七分钟后，我们就到了加沙。它是如此容易，如此迅速，简直令人无法忍受。我的意思是，首先，我们处于震惊中。我处于震惊中。
Chen said this a couple of times in her interview. The part of what was so stunning about being taken hostage was how quick it was. One minute, she was in her home. Minutes later, she's in Gaza, in captivity.
Chen 在采访中提到了好几次。被扣为人质最令人震惊的部分是它发生得太快了。一分钟前，她还在家里。几分钟后，她就在加沙，被囚禁了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I remember like a deserted area. There are papers flying in the air.
我记得像是一个荒凉的地区。有纸片在空中飞舞。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And then they stopped my car. They put us in another car. We drive for a little more. And then a gate opens. The car goes in, and the gate closes.
然后他们拦下了我的车。他们把我们转移到另一辆车上。我们又开了一会儿。然后一扇门打开了。车开进去，门关上了。
They're at a private home. That's where the car stops. Chen say that her kids, till then, had held it together.
他们在一处私人住宅。车就在那里停下。Chen 说她的孩子们直到那时都还表现得很镇定。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
That entire time, the kids were just so, so level-headed. Their conduct was so-- it was amazing. They didn't cry. They didn't do anything dangerous. They didn't yell. They didn't try to hold on to my clothes. I think they even tried to talk to the terrorists, talk to them in English.
在那整个过程中，孩子们都非常、非常冷静。他们的表现是如此……令人惊奇。他们没有哭。他们没有做任何危险的事情。他们没有大喊大叫。他们没有试图抓住我的衣服。我想他们甚至尝试过用英语与恐怖分子交谈。
But now, next to this private home, they see the entrance to a tunnel.
但现在，在这所私人住宅旁边，他们看到了一个地道的入口。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And this is the first time that Tal-- Tal was 9 at the time. This is the first time he's crying. He saw this black hole, and he got scared. Tal cried a bit when he stared at this tunnel, but he calmed down. They brought him water. And that's it. We're going down this tunnel. It's not very deep.
这是 Tal 第一次哭——当时 Tal 9 岁。这是他第一次哭。他看到了这个黑洞，他被吓坏了。Tal 盯着这个地道时哭了一点，但他冷静下来了。他们给他拿了水。就是这样。我们走进这个地道。它不是很深。
And we meet other hostages from Kfar Aza, an elderly couple, a young guy. And each is telling their own kidnapping story. And we can't believe we're in Gaza.
我们遇见了其他来自 Kfar Aza 的人质，一对老夫妇，一个年轻人。每个人都在讲述他们自己的绑架故事。我们无法相信我们真的在加沙。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Can you describe the condition in the tunnel?
[非英语演讲] 你能描述一下地道里的环境吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Sand. There was sand everywhere and also in our mouth. There was a hallway that leads to this small room with some mattresses. There's constant sweeping because there's constant sand. And it's pretty hot there, 27 degrees.
沙子。到处都是沙子，我们的嘴里也有。有一个走廊通向这个放着几张床垫的小房间。因为一直有沙子，所以需要不断清扫。那里非常热，27 摄氏度。
27 degrees, that's 80 degrees Fahrenheit.
27 摄氏度，那是 80 华氏度。
And 27 degrees and very humid, very damp.
27 摄氏度，非常潮湿，非常阴冷。
100 kids plus the three other hostages from the kibbutz were kept in the tunnel for two nights, she says. At one point, one of the guards brings a deck of cards to keep the kids occupied. The boys, remember, were 9 and 11. Agam's the oldest, 17.
她说，100 个孩子加上来自基布兹的其他三名人质被关在地道里两个晚上。有一次，其中一名看守拿出一副扑克牌让孩子们消磨时间。记住，男孩们才 9 岁和 11 岁。Agam 是最大的，17 岁。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And Agam got some sort of a panic attack. She started hyperventilating. She couldn't breathe. And so they attempted to calm her down. They said, you'll be back in Israel by Tuesday. Tuesday, you're back. And this was said on Monday. We were kidnapped on Saturday. And the truth is, I thought so, too. I thought we'll be back by Tuesday.
Agam 惊恐发作了。她开始过度换气。她喘不过气来。所以他们试图让她冷静下来。他们说，周二你就能回到以色列了。周二你就回去了。这话是在周一说的。我们是周六被绑架的。说实话，我也这么想。我以为周二我们就能回去了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
We're in Gaza with children. Israel is not going to attack. Israel is not going to do what it always does. First, they're going to free us, and then they're going to figure out what they're going to do.
我们带着孩子在加沙。以色列不会攻击的。以色列不会做它一贯做的那种事。首先，他们会释放我们，然后他们才会考虑他们要做什么。
On Tuesday, they do leave the tunnel, not for Israel. They're taken to a house next to the tunnel.
周二，他们确实离开了地道，但不是回以色列。他们被带到了地道旁边的一所房子里。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And it's a house that is full of the sounds of kids, babies, women. And there, we can already hear the attacks. Gaza is being bombarded at this point. And then they start prepping us for another move.
那是一所房子，充满了孩子、婴儿、妇女的声音。在那里，我们已经能听到袭击的声音。此时加沙正遭到轰炸。然后他们开始为我们进行下一次转移做准备。
Any move through the streets, where they would be surrounded by Gazans, just random civilians, was always a production because their captors were hiding them from the Israelis, from the general public, from everybody. They didn't want people to know that there were Israeli hostages walking right beside them on the street.
任何穿过街道、会被加沙平民（随机的平民）包围的转移总是像一场制作好的表演，因为绑架者在向以色列人、向公众、向所有人隐瞒他们。他们不想让人们知道就在他们身边的街道上有以色列人质在走动。
So they put Agam and Chen into full length jalabiyas and hijabs. The two boys, Gal and Tal, got hats. Then, they moved them outside. It's five days into the war. Israel's bombarding Gaza. Chen and her kids see Israeli jets flying overhead.
所以他们让 Agam 和 Chen 穿上全长的长袍和头巾。两个男孩 Gal 和 Tal 戴上了帽子。然后，他们把他们带到外面。战争已经五天了。以色列正在轰炸加沙。Chen 和她的孩子们看到以色列喷气式飞机从头顶飞过。
Chen says she and Agam take all this in and say Fauda to each other. Fauda's a big Israeli TV series, an action show about military special ops in the West Bank and Gaza. They end up in an apartment, where they spend the next five weeks, most of their time in Gaza.
Chen 说她和 Agam 领会了这一切，互相说了声“Fauda”。《Fauda》是一部非常受欢迎的以色列电视剧，一部关于西岸和加沙军事特种作战的动作剧。他们最终被带到一个公寓，接下来的五周他们大部分时间都待在那里，在加沙。
Part Two, Daily Life in Captivity. So different hostages say they were held by different militant groups in all sorts of locations and all sorts of conditions. Some hostages who have been released said they were beaten or sexually assaulted.
第二部分：囚禁中的日常生活。所以不同的人质说他们被不同的武装组织关押在各种各样的地方和条件下。一些获释的人质说他们受到了殴打或性侵犯。
Chen's family is now in a residential apartment building guarded by two men, who very much wanted to keep them a secret from all the civilians living around them on all sides, which had lots of consequences for the way they lived. Chen remembers it being really hot in that apartment. They had an electric fan, but electricity was only on for an hour or two a day.
Chen 的家人现在住在一栋居民公寓楼里，由两名男子看守，他们非常想对周围的居民保密，这导致了他们生活方式的诸多后果。Chen 记得公寓里非常热。他们有一个电风扇，但每天只有一两个小时有电。
So it's very hard without the fan when the windows are pretty much closed. There are heavy curtains on the windows, and we weren't allowed to go near them. We weren't allowed-- they keep opening them, closing them, open, close. They don't want anyone to hear us, even people just in the building or, of course, people on the streets.
所以没有电风扇在窗户关得严严实实的情况下非常难熬。窗户上有厚厚的窗帘，我们不被允许靠近它们。我们不被允许——他们一直在开关窗帘，开，关，开，关。他们不想让任何人听到我们的声音，即使只是大楼里的人，或者当然，街道上的人。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I remember it was very hard for me to fall asleep there. I was always the last one, always tossing and turning because you're sweating there the whole time. Everything is wet. You're just soaked in sweat.
我记得在那里我很难入睡。我总是最后一个，总是辗转反侧，因为你在那里一直出汗。一切都是湿的。你只是被汗水浸透了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And there are bombings at night. And at that stage in this apartment where we were, they were still explaining to us, this is bombings from the sky. This is from the sea. This is artillery. And when the house shook, they would move with us, sway with us. And we were on-- I don't know which floor-- maybe fifth?
晚上有轰炸。而在我们所在的那个公寓阶段，他们还在向我们解释：这是从空中来的轰炸，这是从海上来的，这是炮火。当房子摇晃时，他们会和我们一起移动，和我们一起摇摆。我们当时在……我不知道哪一层……也许是五楼？
At that stage, at least, they would say, bida bida, like it's far. You hear the whistle. You know the fall is going to be far. They were trying to tell us it's going to be OK. It's far. They tried to calm us down. They wanted us to be OK.
至少在那个阶段，他们会说“bida bida”，意思是它很远。你听到哨声。你知道爆炸会很远。他们试图告诉我们一切都会好的。它很远。他们试图让我们冷静下来。他们希望我们没事。
Living among the Palestinians, the Israeli hostages suffered through some of the same hardships of the war. Many hostages in their interviews talk about how hungry they were. The captors tried to give them two meals a day.
生活在巴勒斯坦人中间，以色列人质遭受了与战争同样的苦难。许多人质在采访中谈到他们是多么饥饿。看守试图每天给他们提供两顿饭。
As the Israeli bombing campaign progressed, of course, and the army rolled in, food and water got harder and harder to get in Gaza, to the point where now Gaza is on the edge of famine, according to the United Nations.
随着以色列轰炸活动的推进，军队当然开进来了，在加沙获取食物和水变得越来越困难，以至于根据联合国的说法，加沙现在处于饥荒边缘。
Water, they tried to provide drinking water. You can't drink water from the tap. First of all, there isn't like a steady flow of water. Sometimes there's just a drip, and it's basically salt water.
水，他们试图提供饮用水。你不能喝自来水。首先，水没有稳定的供应。有时只有一滴，而且基本上是盐水。
Bathroom, very difficult. Bathrooms, you can't just flush the water. Maybe we had it in the first two days, but then we couldn't flush the water. There was a really bad smell in the bathrooms.
上厕所，非常困难。卫生间，你不能只是冲水。也许前两天我们还能冲水，但后来我们不能冲水了。卫生间里有非常难闻的气味。
When power would come on for an hour, sometimes, she says, they'd get running water. And then they had to decide who could shower-- guards or some of them. Agam, the teenager, really wanted to wash her hair. With all that competition, Chen says, she pretty much gave up on showers for herself.
有时当有一个小时供电时，她说，他们会得到自来水。然后他们必须决定谁能洗澡——看守还是他们中的一些人。十几岁的 Agam 非常想洗头。在所有这些竞争中，Chen 说，她基本上放弃了自己洗澡的念头。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I felt very strange in Gaza physically, the whole stay in Gaza. I was very weak. And I kept thinking about what happened at home. I forced myself to remember how I last saw Yam after she was shot.
我在加沙时身体感觉非常奇怪，整个在加沙的停留期间。我非常虚弱。我一直想着家里发生的事情。我强迫自己回忆 Yam 被枪杀后我最后一次见到她的样子。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Like it was like a form of torture, of self-punishment. Fortunately, over time, as time passes, that image gets blurry. And I remember Yam is beautiful and happy.
就像是一种折磨，一种自我惩罚。幸运的是，随着时间的推移，那张图像变得模糊了。我记得 Yam 是美丽而快乐的。
But I remember at first, I was really forcing myself to not forget how I saw her. I mean, the whole thing just took seconds, and I ran outside. I ran outside to the kids. I didn't go down to help her. I didn't check on her. I was terrified.
但我记得起初，我真的在强迫自己不忘记我看到她的样子。我的意思是，整件事只花了短短几秒钟，我就跑到了外面。我跑向孩子们。我没有下去救她。我没有去查看她的情况。我吓坏了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Looking back now, I realized that in a way, I chose life. I went outside to Agam and Gal and Tal.
现在回想起来，我意识到在某种程度上，我选择了生命。我走到外面去陪 Agam、Gal 和 Tal。
Now, in this apartment, with those three surviving kids, Chen says she was in a constant state of alert to protect them. She says she cried every day, but the captors did not like seeing them cry. She says they wanted them happy, not sad. So she tried to conceal all that.
现在，在这个公寓里，带着那三个幸存的孩子，Chen 说她处于一种持续的戒备状态，以保护他们。她说她每天都在哭，但绑架者不喜欢看到他们哭。她说他们想要他们快乐，而不是悲伤。所以她尽量掩盖这一切。
One night, she says, the apartment started shaking from a bomb that fell nearby, and the guards had them evacuate. They all go into the street.
有一天晚上，她说，公寓开始因附近落下的一枚炸弹而摇晃，看守让他们撤离。他们都走到街上。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
There's total darkness. It's 7:00 PM. And Gaza is destroyed. It's devastated. And we're walking outside. We didn't walk long, but we were outside, me and the kids. And all of a sudden, there was fire on us. I see the red lasers and the balls of fire and shooting on us, fire.
周围一片漆黑。当时是晚上 7 点。加沙被摧毁了。它满目疮痍。我们在外面走着。我们走得不久，但我跟孩子们在外面。突然间，有火向我们袭来。我看到了红色的激光和火球，还有向我们射击的火。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] From airplanes?
[非英语演讲] 是从飞机上来的吗？
That's how it looked like. It came from above, from the air. And they discuss with us many times the absurdity of the fact that they are protecting us from our own military. We had many conversations with them about it, about how absurd it is. And they would really put it in our faces and kind of laugh about and smile about it. And it would be like, do you understand what is going on here? We are watching you. We are protecting you.
看起来就是那样。它是从上面，从空中来的。他们和我们多次讨论了这样一个荒谬的事实：他们在保护我们免受我们自己军队的伤害。我们和他们进行过很多关于此的对话，关于这有多荒谬。他们真的会把它摆在我们面前，以此嘲笑和微笑。就像是，你们明白这里发生了什么吗？我们在看着你们。我们在保护你们。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
There was one night, we spent the night in a supermarket, and it was the first time there was an attack right near us on the street. And the supermarket, the whole place shook. And it's like a crazy jackhammer that's just getting closer and closer to you. We already saw all the rocks coming our way. And it's so scary. It feels like the seconds before death.
有一天晚上，我们在一家超市过夜，那是第一次发生就在我们街道附近的袭击。整个超市的地方都摇晃起来。就像一个疯狂的凿岩机正越来越靠近你。我们已经看到所有的岩石向我们袭来。太可怕了。感觉就像死亡前的几秒钟。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And they are, with their bodies, the terrorists, that cell that watch us, they're, with their bodies, on us, covering us on the mattresses, protecting us, from attacks of our own military.
而他们，那些恐怖分子，那个看守我们的核心小组，他们用他们的身体覆盖在我们身上，在床垫上保护我们，免受我们自己军队的攻击。
The complicated relationship they had with their captors. That's the subject of Part Three, The Guards. In general, the only Hamas members who talk to the media are official spokespeople and leaders. And one of the things about these hostage interviews is that they give a glimpse of lower level operatives, some Hamas, some with other militant groups operating in Gaza who are keeping Israelis hostage. Here's Lee Naim, the interviewer.
他们与绑架者之间复杂的关系。那是第三部分：看守的话题。总的来说，唯一与媒体交谈的哈马斯成员是官方发言人和领导人。这些关于人质的采访的一个特点是，它们让我们得以一窥低层人员——有些人是哈马斯，有些人是其他在加沙开展活动的武装组织——这些人把以色列人扣为人质。这是采访者 Lee Naim。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] At the end of the day, these are the people holding you, and your life depends on them. So, with all the hate, I assume it was very uncomfortable situation. I imagine myself, I want them to like me so I can survive. So how did you manage it? [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲] 归根结底，这些人扣押了你们，你的生命掌握在他们手中。所以，带着所有的仇恨，我想这是一个非常不舒服的情况。我想象自己，我想让他们喜欢我，这样我才能活下来。所以你是怎么做到的？[非英语演讲]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Yeah, we realized our lives are in their hands. We realized they were just a cog in the system, that they're not the people making the decisions. Sometimes I would ask them, if someone gave you the decision to hurt us, would you do that? And they would say, no, we are going to die before that happens. Worst case, we're all going to die together. And that was pretty encouraging to hear.
是的，我们意识到我们的生命掌握在他们手中。我们意识到他们只是系统中的一颗齿轮，他们不是做决定的人。有时我会问他们，如果有人让你伤害我们，你会那么做吗？他们会说，不，在那之前我们就会死。最坏的情况，我们都会一起死。听到这些真是令人鼓舞。
Chen says that eventually there were four men guarding her family, who told them they were 28, 30, 37, and 44 years old, three married, two with kids. The youngest had a failed engagement. The oldest was the most religious, Chen said. He would read the most. One of them was learning Hebrew and would ask Agam if she could help him study years or dates.
Chen 说最终有四名男子看守她的家人，他们告诉他们自己分别是 28 岁、30 岁、37 岁和 44 岁，三个已婚，两个有孩子。最小的订婚失败了。最大的最虔诚，Chen 说。他读书最多。其中一个在学希伯来语，会问 Agam 是否能帮他学习年份或日期。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] What was the most surprising thing that you discovered about them?
[非英语演讲] 你发现关于他们最令人惊讶的事情是什么？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Mm, their sensitivity at times, how much they miss their wives. At some point, one of them wrote a letter to his wife, and it was contagious because then another one wrote a letter to his wife.
嗯，他们有时表现出的敏感，他们是多么想念他们的妻子。在某个时候，他们中的一个人给他妻子写了一封信，这具有感染力，因为后来另一个人也给他妻子写了一封信。
I'm just going to interrupt here because I just want to point out the intimacy of this-- these people locked together in a dark, hot, stuffy apartment, planes dropping bombs around them, who cannot help but notice what the others are doing in this cramped space. It's so personal. But at the same time, they are not on the same team. There's a distance. So when Chen and Agam see them all writing letters to their wives--
我要在这里打断一下，因为我只想指出这种亲密关系的性质——这些人被关在一起，在一个黑暗、闷热、空气不流通的公寓里，周围是投下炸弹的飞机，他们禁不住注意到其他人在这个狭窄的空间里在做什么。这太私人了。但与此同时，他们不是一伙的。有一段距离。所以当 Chen 和 Agam 看到他们都在给妻子写信时——
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And it made us really nervous, Agam and I. We were like, why do you need to write letters to your wives right now? Is something going on? Is there something about to happen? One of them said he had an agreement with his wife to put the letter in his pocket, so if they found his body, they find it in the pocket. We saw their pain, sometimes. We could see their pain. We saw them breaking down and cry.
这让我们非常紧张，我和 Agam。我们想，为什么你们现在需要给妻子写信？发生什么事了吗？有什么事情要发生了吗？其中一个人说他和妻子达成了一个协议，要把信放在他的口袋里，如果他们发现了他的尸体，就在口袋里发现它。我们有时看到了他们的痛苦。我们能看到他们的痛苦。我们看到他们崩溃和哭泣。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] What did they cry over?
[非英语演讲] 他们因为什么而哭？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
About the uncertainty of what's going on with their family, whether their family was hurt or no. That was the main thing.
关于他们家人状况的不确定性，他们的家人是否受伤，或者没有。那是主要的事情。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Did they see you as human beings?
[非英语演讲] 他们把你们视为人类吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Yeah, it seems so. Yeah. Yes. I mean, I felt like they really liked Gal and Tal, despite all the harm that was done. And there was harm done.
是的，看起来是这样。是的。是的。我的意思是，我觉得他们真的喜欢 Gal 和 Tal，尽管所有的伤害都已经造成了。确实造成了伤害。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Beyond their activity in Hamas, they also had a business of perfumes. And they really showed us. They brought a box with all the perfumes. They wanted Agam and I to check it out, to try it, and tell them what we thought, what we liked. They really showed us the syringes, how they make it with the percentages of the alcohol, how they put it all together.
除了他们在哈马斯的活动外，他们还经营香水生意。他们真的向我们展示了。他们带了一个装满所有香水的盒子。他们想让 Agam 和我看看，试试它，告诉他们我们的想法，我们喜欢什么。他们真的向我们展示了注射器，他们是如何按酒精比例制作它的，他们是如何把它组装在一起的。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
We also started having conversations about the roots and the depth of the conflict.
我们也开始就冲突的根源和深度进行了对话。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
From their perspective, we were the first ones who murdered. We were the ones who deported and murdered their parents in '48.
从他们的角度来看，我们是首先实施谋杀的人。我们是 1948 年流放并杀害他们父母的人。
1948, the year Israel became a state. The violence in that period resulted in the deaths of 15,000 Palestinians and the displacement of over 750,000 others.
1948 年，以色列建国的那一年。那一时期的暴力事件导致了 15,000 名巴勒斯坦人死亡，超过 750,000 人流离失所。
When the conversation reached those points, that's when we would stop because it would just get too tense. Because we didn't agree with them, but on the other hand, we also didn't know all the facts to argue with them. So we didn't want to upset them too much. We wanted to be OK with them.
当谈话达到那些点时，我们就会停止，因为气氛太紧张了。因为我们不同意他们的观点，但另一方面，我们也不知道所有事实来和他们争论。所以我们不想让他们太难受。我们想和他们相处得还可以。
Sometimes, though, Chen couldn't help herself. Like, she says, every time they were moved from one apartment to another, passed from one group of captors to the next, the new ones would always ask, is this the family?
不过，有时 Chen 无法克制自己。她说，每次他们从一个公寓搬到另一个，从一组绑架者传到下一组时，新来的人总是会问，这是那个家庭吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And then I needed to explain to them that, yes, you murdered my husband, you murdered my daughter, so this is the family. And then sometimes after that, there would be a silence. And sometimes they would say that if the person who murdered Yam and Nadav did it in vain, like if Yam and Nadav weren't a real threat, that person, on the day of his death, he will be judged. If he killed them in vain, he'll go to hell. If not, he'll go to paradise.
然后我需要向他们解释，是的，你们杀了我的丈夫，你们杀了我的女儿，所以这就是那个家庭。然后有时在那之后，会出现一阵沉默。有时他们会说，如果那个杀害 Yam 和 Nadav 的人是徒劳地做的，比如如果 Yam 和 Nadav 不是真正的威胁，那个人在他死亡的那天会被审判。如果他是徒劳地杀了他们，他会下地狱。如果不是，他会去天堂。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Sometimes there was this moment of silence, or they would apologize when they realized that their own people, their brothers, killed Nadav and Yam.
有时会出现那一刻的沉默，或者当他们意识到他们自己的人，他们的兄弟，杀死了 Nadav 和 Yam 时，他们会道歉。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Generally, though, her captors were pretty unrepentant and open about their hopes for the future.
不过总的来说，她的绑架者对未来相当不知悔改，并且公开表达了他们的希望。
They also told us, we like you. You're a good family. Don't go back to Kfar Azam. We'll come back there again. How many were we last time? Like 3,000? How many people you think we have in our organizations? They ask me and Agam.
他们还告诉我们，我们喜欢你们。你们是个好家庭。不要回 Kfar Aza 了。我们会再回到那里的。我们上次有多少人？比如 3,000？你们认为我们的组织里有多少人？他们问我和 Agam。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Agam and I would try 20,000, 40,000. So we'll come, they say, in three years. In three years, we'll rebuild, and then 40,000 will come again. They were in euphoria. In the seven weeks that we were there in Gaza, our impression was that they were elated over their success on October 7, and that they planned to come again. We never got the impression that their spirits are being hurt because of the attacks.
我和 Agam 会试着说 20,000，40,000。所以他们说，我们会来，在三年内。在三年内，我们将重建，然后 40,000 人会再次到来。他们沉浸在狂喜中。在我们待在加沙的七周里，我们的印象是他们对 10 月 7 日的成功感到欢欣鼓舞，并且他们计划再次来袭。我们从未得到过他们的精神因攻击而受到伤害的印象。
Part Four, News From Home. There was a radio in the apartment. And sometimes the guards would let Chen and her family listen. But it was an ordeal to get them to agree to that. When the news came on, they would beg to be allowed to listen to 10 minutes' worth.
第四部分：来自家里的新闻。公寓里有一台收音机。有时看守会让 Chen 和她的家人听。但让他们同意这一点简直是一种折磨。当新闻开始时，他们会恳求被允许听 10 分钟。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
A newscast where they didn't talk about the hostages really broke our hearts. We just couldn't accept that they are talking about deepening the fighting, and they don't talk about us. And when we came back, we actually talked about it. And we noticed that ever since, they are making an effort to always, at the top of the hour, to mention the hostages, because we really waited for it every time.
一个没有谈论人质的新闻广播真的让我们伤透了心。我们只是无法接受他们在谈论深化战斗，却不谈论我们。当我们回来时，我们实际上谈到了这一点。我们注意到从那以后，他们确实在努力，总是在整点提及人质，因为我们每次真的都在等待它。
Listening to the radio, they started to piece together how big the attacks of October 7 had been. They had no idea of the scope. Other hostages said this, too.
听着收音机，他们开始拼凑出 10 月 7 日的袭击规模有多大。他们完全不知道范围。其他人质也这么说。
One told the interviewer that she was shocked to hear that 75 people from her kibbutz, a fifth of the kibbutz, had been taken hostage. She thought it was just her and the three other people who she'd met in captivity. Chen was listening to a broadcast when her own father came on the air, talking about them.
一位人质告诉采访者，她震惊地听说她所在的基布兹有 75 人，即基布兹的五分之一，被扣为人质。她以为只有她和她在囚禁中遇到的其他三个人。Chen 正在听广播时，她自己的父亲在广播里谈论他们。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And the radio host is saying goodbye and saying, we're sorry for Nadav and Yam. That's when I finally realized that they're not with us anymore.
广播主持人正在道别并说，我们为 Nadav 和 Yam 感到难过。那时我才终于意识到他们已经不再和我们在一起了。
Up until then, she'd held out hope that maybe the army had come right afterwards and saved Nadav.
在那之前，她一直怀有希望，也许军队在袭击后不久就来了，救了 Nadav。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
That was the first time that Gal, who's 12, now is 12, cried. We were really moved to hear my dad on one hand and on the other hand, very, very sad. And still we kept asking for the radio.
那是 12 岁的 Gal——现在是 12 岁——第一次哭。我们一方面听到我爸爸的声音，感到非常感动，另一方面感到非常、非常悲伤。但我们仍然一直在要收音机。
One day on the radio, they heard about the dramatic rescue of a hostage named Ori Megidish by the Israeli military. That news really seemed to get to their guards. The guards started acting very differently.
有一天在广播里，他们听到了以色列军队戏剧性营救了一名名叫 Ori Megidish 的人质的消息。那条新闻似乎确实让他们的看守受到影响。看守开始表现得非常不同。
They started going crazy. They wore their bulletproof vests, and they put their uniforms-- they became more like soldiers. Their stress immediately affected us, was projected on us.
他们开始发疯了。他们穿上防弹背心，穿上他们的制服——他们变得更像士兵了。他们的压力立刻影响了我们，投射到了我们身上。
I remember at some point, they were also taking out some sort of grenade, in case someone is going to break the door. And they told us, if they're going to break the door, we're all going to hide in the bathroom together. It was just awful stress.
我记得在某个时候，他们还拿出了某种手榴弹，以防有人要破门而入。他们告诉我们，如果他们要破门，我们就一起躲在卫生间里。那真是可怕的压力。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] And the news about Ori, did it encourage you or stress you in any way?
[非英语演讲] 关于 Ori 的新闻，它有没有以任何方式鼓励你或让你感到压力？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I mean, we were jealous of her. We were jealous that they were able to get to her and rescue her. But we also-- we saw what it did to our guards. That's why, after they rescued the last three hostages two months ago, I immediately thought-- I mean, it's a happy thing. Each one is a universe. It's a life.
我的意思是，我们嫉妒她。我们嫉妒他们能够接触到她并救出她。但我们也……我们看到了它对我们看守的影响。这就是为什么在两个月前他们救出最后三名人质后，我立刻想——我的意思是，这是一件快乐的事情。每一个都是一个宇宙。这是一个生命。
But I immediately thought, what does it mean for the people still there? Are they being guarded more intensely? Are they being transferred from one place to another now? I was scared. Maybe they're hurting them more. Maybe they're doing something to them now.
但我立刻想到，这对仍然在那里的人意味着什么？他们是否被更严密地看守了？他们现在是否从一个地方被转移到另一个地方了？我很害怕。也许他们正对他们造成更多伤害。也许他们现在正在对他们做些什么。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Chen Almog-Goldstein being interviewed by Lee Naim. The story continues. And we hear from other hostages, including one who met the head of Hamas in a tunnel. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Chen Almog-Goldstein 接受 Lee Naim 的采访。故事还在继续。我们将听到其他人的声音，包括一个在地道里见过哈马斯领导人的人。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续，我们的节目还在进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, 51 Days. A year after the Hamas attack on Israel that started the current war, we're hearing the story of Chen Almog-Goldstein, who was held hostage with three of her kids for 51 days.
这里是《这是美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。今天的节目，51 天。在哈马斯袭击以色列引发当前战争的一年后，我们正在听 Chen Almog-Goldstein 的故事，她和她的三个孩子被当作人质扣押了 51 天。
And before we get back to her story, I wanted to play you a few clips from some of the other interviews that Lee Naim did with hostages for the Israeli news podcast, Echad Bayom-- One a Day. One of the interviews she did gave a glimpse of life in a tunnel that's very different from Chen's experience.
在我们回到她的故事之前，我想播放一些 Lee Naim 为以色列新闻播客《Echad Bayom》（一天一个）采访其他人质的片段。她做的其中一次采访让我们瞥见了与 Chen 的经历大不相同的地道生活。
This is somebody who spent her entire time in captivity in the tunnels, a 78-year-old named Margalit Moses. And to give you a sense of her personality, her captors at some point started calling her the captain, because in that particular group of hostages, she would be the one to suggest things to the guards, like don't cook the potatoes in the morning and then serve them to us hours later. Cook them shortly before we eat them and bring them warm. Put them on a plate with a bit of salt. People like salt on their potatoes.
这是一位在囚禁期间一直待在地道里的人，一位 78 岁名叫 Margalit Moses 的老人。为了让你了解她的个性，她的看守在某个时候开始称她为“船长”，因为在那特定的人质群体中，她是那个会向看守提建议的人，比如不要在早上把土豆煮好，几个小时后再端给我们。要在我们吃之前不久把它们煮好，热着送来。把它们放在盘子里，撒一点盐。人们喜欢在土豆上撒盐。
Margalit says, when she arrived in Gaza, they walked deep into the tunnels an hour and a half or two hours before they arrived at the rooms underground, where she and about 15 people from her kibbutz were held. There were mattresses on the floor and chairs.
Margalit 说，当她到达加沙时，他们在地道里走了半个小时或两个小时，才到达地下室，她和大约 15 名来自她基布兹的人被关在那里。地板上有床垫和椅子。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Oh, we had an elegant room, really. We had a room that was covered with ceramics, both the floors and the walls.
噢，我们有一个优雅的房间，真的。我们有一个房间，地板和墙壁都铺着瓷砖。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Except for the ceiling that was both curved and painted white with lime. The walls were decorated with a beautiful, delicate design. And high up above, there were drawings of tulips with beautiful green leaves.
除了天花板是弯曲的，涂着白色的石灰。墙壁装饰着美丽、精致的设计。在高处，有郁金香的图画，绿叶优美。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] How organized and prepared did the tunnels there seem?
[非英语演讲] 那里的地道看起来有多么有组织和准备充分？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Oh, the tunnels were very, very organized. I walked around even at night. I didn't have that much to do, unless somebody wanted to go to the bathroom, and I helped them.
噢，地道非常有条理。我甚至在晚上走动。我没什么事可做，除非有人想上厕所，我会帮他们。
Margalit was up all night because she's somebody who needs a CPAP machine to sleep. She brought one with her, but her captors took it. And then she asked a doctor for another one. She said he smiled and laughed and said, we don't have those here. So, she says, she didn't sleep for more than 5 or 10 minutes at a time for nearly two months. So at night, up anyway, she would walk people to the toilet.
Margalit 整夜没睡，因为她是一个需要 CPAP 机才能睡觉的人。她带了一台来，但被她的看守拿走了。然后她向一名医生要了另一台。她说他微笑着笑了笑，说，我们这里没有那种东西。所以，她说，近两个月里，她几乎没有连续睡超过 5 或 10 分钟。所以晚上无论如何都醒着，她会陪人去上厕所。
So I was walking around at night in the tunnels. And generally, we were only allowed to get to a certain point beyond which they said, you can't go. And I constantly was wondering, what is there that they don't let us go there? Do they have some weapons there? Or-- I don't know what.
所以我晚上在地道里走来走去。总的来说，我们只被允许走到某个点，超过那个点他们就说，你不能去。我一直很奇怪，那边有什么他们不让我们去的地方？他们那里有什么武器吗？或者……我不知道是什么。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
So one night, when I saw that they were all asleep, even that person that was supposed to be awake to supposedly watch over us. So I said, I really have to go see what's there.
所以有一天晚上，当我看到他们都睡着了，甚至那个应该醒着守卫我们的人也睡着了。所以我说，我真的必须去看看那里有什么。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And then I arrive, and I see that there was a splitting of a few tunnels. So I peeked to see into each one what's there.
然后我到了，我看到有几个地道的分叉。所以我窥视每个地道，看看里面有什么。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Here, there is this one tunnel full to the brim with lots of six-packs of mineral water. So straight away, one bottle here, one bottle there.
这里，有一个地道装满了许多六瓶装的矿泉水。所以直接，拿一瓶在这里，一瓶在那里。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] You hid them.
[非英语演讲] 你藏了它们。
Yes. And that's how we had mineral water, at least for a few days.
是的。就这样我们至少有了几天的矿泉水。
She said one tunnel she looked down had mattresses. Others had electrical wires and water pipes. Near their room in the tunnel, there was a kitchenette with shelves for canned food, and there was a group of hostages that were in a room that was mostly open but had some cages, she said, like for prisoners on the side.
她说她看的一个地道里有床垫。其他地道里有电线和水管。在地道里他们的房间附近，有一个带货架的小厨房用来放罐头食品，还有一群人质关在一个大部分是开放但有一些笼子的房间里，她说，就像旁边关押囚犯的地方。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
So it was really organized, from their point of view, the tunnels. Numbers, each floor a different color. They sometimes had to walk around with notes that explained to them where to turn because the place is huge.
所以从他们的角度来看，地道确实组织得很好。有数字，每一层是不同的颜色。他们有时必须带着说明在哪儿转弯的纸条走动，因为这个地方太大了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Maps?
[非英语演讲] 地图？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Maps, yes, maps. We reached minus 5, sometimes.
地图，是的，地图。我们有时达到地下 5 层。
Minus 5, five floors down.
地下 5 层，五层楼深。
When they were afraid there might be soldiers outside, they called us to come quickly, quickly. So we went downstairs quickly. And then we saw minus 5. So just imagine kilometers and kilometers and five floors.
当他们害怕外面可能有士兵时，他们叫我们快点，快点。所以我们快速下楼。然后我们看到了地下 5 层。所以想象一下几公里又几公里，还有五层楼。
Incredibly, one day, the second day of their captivity, Margalit says they had a visit from the man responsible for their kidnapping and the deaths of their loved ones, the head of Hamas himself, Yahya Sinwar.
令人难以置信的是，有一天，即他们被囚禁的第二天，Margalit 说他们接待了一位对绑架他们及他们亲人死亡负有责任的人，即哈马斯头目本人，叶海亚·辛瓦尔。
Can I say, I find this to be a completely believable story because nothing dramatic happens in this story at all. Like, if you made up a story like this, the head of Hamas would say something fascinating and revealing, or she would get off some great line. None of that happens. It just seems like he ordered people to bring back hostages. They did. It's the next day, and he wants to see some of them for himself. Here's Margalit's account.
我可以这样说，我觉得这是一个完全可信的故事，因为在这个故事中根本没有发生什么戏剧性的事。就像，如果你编造了这样一个故事，哈马斯头目会说一些令人着迷和揭示真相的话，或者她会说出一句精彩的台词。这些都没发生。这看起来只是他命令人们带回人质。他们照做了。第二天，他想亲自看看他们中的一些人。这是 Margalit 的描述。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
He entered the room with his entourage. He asked us, do you know who I am? So I said to him, yes, you are Yahya Sinwar. So he opened his eyes big. He was surprised I knew his name. And he said, yes, it's true. I'm Yahya Sinwar. He speaks fluent Hebrew very well. And he said not to be afraid. And they will give us anything we need, and that we are only there to be bargaining chips for prisoner exchange.
他带着随从进了房间。他问我们，你们知道我是谁吗？所以我对他说，是的，你是叶海亚·辛瓦尔。所以他瞪大了眼睛。他很惊讶我知道他的名字。他说，是的，没错。我是叶海亚·辛瓦尔。他能说一口非常流利的希伯来语。他说不要害怕。他们会给我们任何我们需要的东西，我们只是那里的谈判筹码，用于囚犯交换。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] How did it feel to hear that from him?
[非英语演讲] 听到他这么说是什么感觉？
[EXHALES] It's horrifying. The audacity with which he said it with his nose up in the air. For me, it was an unpleasant moment. This arrogance of his humiliates you, and most of us were older people. What is the point of kidnapping older people and putting them there?
[叹气] 令人毛骨悚然。他昂着头说这些话时的厚颜无耻。对我来说，这是一个不愉快的时刻。他的这种傲慢让你感到屈辱，而我们大多数人都是老年人。绑架老年人并把他们关在那里有什么意义？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
So that's Margalit Moses, who was released around the same time as Chen and her family. I want to play you some stuff from one other interview before we get back to Chen. Ada Sagi is 75 years old, from the same kibbutz as Margalit.
这就是 Margalit Moses，她和 Chen 及其家人在大约同一时间获释。回到 Chen 的故事之前，我想播放另一段采访。Ada Sagi 今年 75 岁，和 Margalit 来自同一个基布兹。
Her life in captivity was very different from Margalit's or Chen's for a few reasons, and one of them is that she speaks Arabic, taught it in middle schools, partly out of an idealistic belief in coexistence and wanting to speak with her neighbors. And so she understood what was being said around her when she was in captivity, understood where she was October 7, when she was driven south to the city of Khan Younis.
她在囚禁中的生活与 Margalit 或 Chen 的非常不同，原因有几个，其中之一是她会说阿拉伯语，曾在中学教过阿拉伯语，部分源于一种对共存的理想主义信念，以及想与邻居交谈的愿望。所以当她被囚禁时，她听懂了周围说的话，在 10 月 7 日她被开车送往南方汗尤尼斯市时，她知道自己在哪里。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
We arrived at a vegetable sorting warehouse at the eastern outskirts of Khan Younis. They unloaded us, took from us some jewelry that I had from my mother, wedding band, and my glasses.
我们到达了汗尤尼斯东郊的一个蔬菜分拣仓库。他们把我们卸下，拿走了我从母亲那里得到的一些珠宝，结婚戒指，还有我的眼镜。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And I begged them to leave the glasses, because without them, I completely lose orientation. They took it because they claimed that it has a tracking chip in it. And they are petrified by chips.
我恳求他们留下眼镜，因为没有它们，我完全失去了方向感。他们拿走了它，因为他们声称它里面有一个跟踪芯片。他们对芯片感到恐惧。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Did you try to explain that--
[非英语演讲] 你尝试解释过——
Yes, I tried to explain them. What do I have in common with a chip? Well, they said you used to be a soldier.
是的，我试着向他们解释。我和芯片有什么共同点？好吧，他们说你曾经是个士兵。
They said that to a 75-year-old woman because there is mandatory military service in Israel. So she served.
他们对一位 75 岁的老妇人说这些，因为以色列有强制兵役制。所以她服过兵役。
But when I was a soldier, there was no computer, and there were no chips. They explained that every soldier has a chip. And I said, I wish it was true. If it was true, we would know where everybody is.
但我当兵时，没有电脑，也没有芯片。他们解释说每个士兵都有一个芯片。我说，我希望是真的。如果那是真的，我们就会知道每个人在哪里。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
In that warehouse, somebody stood and did the check-in. He was an English-speaking person. He asked for first name, last name, ID number from where we are. And he also was asking for the phone number of the children. Naturally, I invented phone numbers.
在那个仓库里，有人站着做了登记。那是一个讲英语的人。他询问名字、姓氏、身份证号码、我们从哪里来。他还问了孩子们的电话号码。自然，我编造了电话号码。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I said, it's like check-in into a hotel.
我说，这就像办理入住酒店一样。
Another fact about Ada-- she left her home without putting on shoes. Her captors told her, don't put them on. So she spent her entire captivity barefoot, though she was given a pair of socks in November, when it got colder.
关于 Ada 的另一个事实——她离家时没有穿鞋。她的绑架者告诉她，不要穿上它们。所以她整个囚禁期间都是赤脚，尽管在 11 月天冷时她得到了一双袜子。
Ada was held captive with another woman from her kibbutz, Meyrav Tal, who's in her 50s, 20 years younger than Ada, not somebody she knew well before this. But the fact that there was somebody else to share this with really defined her time as a hostage and made it easier.
Ada 与来自她基布兹的另一位女性 Meyrav Tal 被关在一起，Meyrav 50 多岁，比 Ada 小 20 岁，并不是在此之前她熟悉的人。但有另一个人可以分享这段经历的事实确实定义了她作为人质的时间，并使日子变得更容易。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
They put us in the children's bedroom. There were two bunk beds. They gave us the lower beds. I had the drawing of Angry Birds, and Meyrav had the drawing of sweet dreams.
他们把我们关在孩子们的卧室里。那里有两张双层床。他们给了我们下铺。我那张床有“愤怒的小鸟”的图画，Meyrav 那张床有“甜蜜梦想”的图画。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] How did you pass the time, you and Meyrav?
[非英语演讲] 你和 Meyrav 是怎么打发时间的？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Hours and hours of logic games. And we were playing a crossword puzzle in our heads. We were talking about our family, every child, grandchild. We got to know each other family as if the two of us were sisters.
数小时又数小时的逻辑游戏。我们在脑子里玩填字游戏。我们谈论我们的家庭，每个孩子，孙子。我们了解彼此的家庭，就像我们俩是姐妹一样。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Did you also share your worries?
[非英语演讲] 你们也分享了你们的担忧吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Yes we were very, very much partners in our worries.
是的，我们在担忧中确实非常、非常亲密。
They also talked to their guards. One guard spoke some English, and Ada, of course, spoke Arabic. One of the guards in particular, she says, was very loyal to her and Meyrav. He listened to Al Jazeera and told them what was happening in the news.
她们也和看守们交谈。一个看守会说一点英语，Ada 当然会说阿拉伯语。她说，其中一个看守对她和 Meyrav 非常忠诚。他听半岛电视台，并告诉她们新闻里发生了什么。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
He said all the time that I'm treating you as if you were my mother. I felt that there is some respect. We know that his wife is a midwife at the Nasser Hospital in Khan Younis. He has four kids. He evacuated her and the kids from the home to her parents' home.
他一直说，我把你们当作我的母亲一样对待。我觉得这里面有一些尊重。我们知道他的妻子是汗尤尼斯纳赛尔医院的一名助产士。他有四个孩子。他把她和孩子们从家里撤离到她父母家。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Oh, he really told you about himself.
[非英语演讲] 噢，他真的告诉了你们关于他自己的事情。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Yes, he told us a lot. At one time, while he was telling that-- he said, I'm not involved. And I said, what do you mean, not involved? And he said, I'm neither a Jihad nor Hamas, but I want money.
是的，他告诉了我们很多。有一次，当他告诉这些时——他说，我没有参与。我说，你什么意思，没有参与？他说，我既不是圣战分子也不是哈马斯，但我想要钱。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I ask him, but myself and Meyrav are at your place in the kids' room. You took away our freedom, our basic right, and you say that you are not involved?
我问他，但我自己和 Meyrav 在你这里的孩子房间里。你夺走了我们的自由，我们的基本权利，你说你没有参与？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And he said, I want money. I want money for myself and my wife to get visa for us and the kids and fly away from here because there is no future here.
他说，我想要钱。我想要钱让我和妻子拿到签证，带着孩子们飞离这里，因为这里没有未来。
OK, back to Chen and her family. We are at part 5, Moving Around. One of the things you realize, listening to Chen, is just how much of the experience of being a hostage can be just being moved from place to place, no idea where you are or where you're going or why.
好的，回到 Chen 和她的家人。我们现在是第五部分：到处走动。听 Chen 讲述时你意识到的一件事是，作为人质的经历很大程度上只是被从一个地方移到另一个地方，完全不知道你在哪里，你要去哪里，或者为什么要搬。
Chen's daughter, Agam, worried every time they were moved that this was the time they were going to be taken somewhere to be killed. When they walk through the streets, they're supposed to keep their eyes down and blend in. The captors gave them fake names to use if anybody tried to talk to them. And they would practice the pronunciation of the names with them to be sure they got them right.
Chen 的女儿 Agam 每次他们被搬迁时都会担心这是他们被带去某个地方杀害的时候。当他们走在街上时，他们被要求低着头，混在人群中。绑架者给了他们假名字，以备有人尝试和他们交谈时使用。他们会和他们练习名字的发音，以确保他们说对了。
That night they thought they might die in that supermarket, Chen and her kids were moved to an apartment above the supermarket til that building started shaking. It didn't seem safe, and they moved to a mosque for shelter. And then they headed out on what Chen remembers as a long journey through the streets of Gaza, part of it on a donkey cart.
那天晚上他们以为自己会死在那个超市里，Chen 和她的孩子们被转移到超市上方的一间公寓，直到那栋楼开始摇晃。看起来不安全，他们就转移到一座清真寺避难。然后他们开始了 Chen 记忆中一段漫长的旅程，穿过加沙的街道，其中一部分是骑驴车。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Eight of us on a donkey, like on a cart attached to a donkey. And the donkey is stumbling.
我们八个人坐在一头驴上，就像坐在一辆驴车上。驴在跌跌撞撞。
And bombing all around?
周围到处都是轰炸？
Bombings, yeah, and roads that would end. And they would have to ask the locals whether we can pass through or not. And then the donkey would need to make a U-turn.
轰炸，是的，还有走到尽头的路。他们不得不问当地人我们是否可以通过。然后驴不得不掉头。
Finally, they reached an apartment, which she says was still under construction. Maybe a month and a half into their captivity, not long before the end, one of the guards takes Chen and her kids out of the apartment and onto the street.
最后，他们到达了一间公寓，她说那还在施工中。可能在囚禁了一个半月后，离结束不久，其中一名看守把 Chen 和她的孩子们带出公寓，带到了街上。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Very long walk in the streets of Gaza. We're outside, and for the first time, we see the sun down. And then we get to a school.
在加沙的街道上走了很长时间。我们在外面，这是第一次我们看到太阳落山。然后我们到了一个学校。
All around the school are Palestinian civilians who are seeking shelter. And Chen and her kids, in their disguises, apparently look like just another displaced Palestinian family needing help.
学校周围都是正在寻求避难的巴勒斯坦平民。Chen 和她的孩子们穿着伪装，看起来显然就像另一个需要帮助的流离失所的巴勒斯坦家庭。
People were putting all these sheets and putting together these impromptu tents. And there's a lot of people there. And they approached the guy from the cell, and they offer to house us, to host us. He kept saying that people are offering help because they see family with kids. So they offer to help.
人们搭起所有这些床单，把这些临时帐篷凑在一起。那里有很多人。他们接近了那个核心小组的人，他们提议安置我们，接待我们。他一直说人们提供帮助是因为他们看到有孩子的家庭。所以他们提供帮助。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
For the first time after six weeks, we're sitting outside, and we're seeing the moon. And Tal is telling me, hey, Mom, look, this is the moon. And there was excitement in the air, too, because there was a feeling of like a ceasefire might be coming.
六周以来第一次，我们坐在外面，我们看到了月亮。Tal 告诉我，嘿，妈妈，看，那是月亮。气氛中也有兴奋，因为有一种感觉，好像停火可能就要来了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Did you believe it?
[非英语演讲] 你相信吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Yeah, it looked like-- yes, I wished for it. And then I look at the sky, and I show Tal. And I tell him, look which stars are moving and which stars are staying still because the skies were packed with planes.
是的，看起来……是的，我希望如此。然后我看向天空，我指给 Tal 看。我告诉他，看哪颗星星在移动，哪颗星星保持不动，因为天空挤满了飞机。
And then all of a sudden, people near the school launched rockets, and they were so thrilled with every rocket they launched. And I was immediately scared. Maybe now the planes are going to bomb the school.
然后突然间，学校附近的人发射了火箭，他们对发射的每一枚火箭都感到非常兴奋。我立刻感到害怕。也许现在飞机要轰炸学校了。
Then she says, the guard who was with them, who had been with them for weeks, said goodbye to Chen, wished them a quick return to Israel, told her to take good care of Agam, and handed her off to the next group of captors. They were told there's no safe place above ground anymore and got taken down into a tunnel, where they met six other hostages, two kids, four women, two of whom are young Israeli soldiers.
然后她说，一直和他们在一起的看守，那个已经和他们在一起几周的人，和 Chen 道别了，祝愿他们早日回到以色列，告诉她要好好照顾 Agam，并将她交给了下一组绑架者。他们被告知地面上已经没有安全的地方了，并被带进了一个地道，在那里他们遇到了另外六名人质：两个孩子，四名妇女，其中两人是年轻的以色列女兵。
They had just finished basic training and a course, and they didn't even start doing their job. Kids, they're like 18 and 1/2, 19-year-olds. Some of them were alone until they got to that tunnel. And some were physically injured, alone. Yeah, some of them went through a lot.
她们刚完成基本训练和课程，甚至还没开始工作。孩子，她们就像 18 岁半、19 岁。她们中有些人被单独关押直到她们到达那个地道。有些人身体受伤，孤身一人。是的，她们中的一些人经历了很多。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
There was something really powerful about that week in that tunnel. Even though with all the difficulties and even though they seemed to be on edge, we were really there for one another. There was some sort of feminine energy strength in that tunnel.
在地道里的那一周有一些真正强大的东西。尽管有所有的困难，尽管她们似乎都很紧张，我们确实是在互相支持。那个地道里有一种女性力量的能量。
The two kids, Ela and Dafna, were sisters, 8 and 15. Their dad and his partner were killed on October 7. And the other women had been taking care of them in Gaza.
那两个孩子，Ela 和 Dafna，是姐妹，8 岁和 15 岁。她们的父亲和他的伴侣在 10 月 7 日被杀。其他女性一直在加沙照顾她们。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And they're amazing. They showed so much emotional strength also towards the children, Dafna and Ela. And that's something I couldn't handle.
她们太棒了。她们表现出了如此多的情感力量，也对孩子们（Dafna 和 Ela）表现出来了。这是我无法应付的事情。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] To be there for other kids.
[非英语演讲] 去陪伴其他孩子。
Yes, I couldn't. But the young women, they were there for them. They were with them even before we arrived. So they were the authority for those girls.
是的，我不能。但那些年轻女性，她们陪伴着她们。在我们到达之前，她们就和她们在一起了。所以她们是那些女孩的权威。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And I was in awe, truly, at how they managed to handle them and be there for them, with their physical injuries and with their emotional injuries, and still try to function, to cook whenever possible, to be there for each other.
我真的很敬畏，她们竟然设法处理并陪伴她们，带着她们的身体创伤和情感创伤，仍然试图发挥功能，尽可能地做饭，互相陪伴。
I remember one day, one of them had this like panic attack. And she started hyperventilating, and she started going up the stairs. And she sat there on the stairs, and she was crying her heart out. And she was crying. And she just like-- it's like she couldn't breathe.
我记得有一天，其中一个惊恐发作了。她开始过度换气，她开始走上楼梯。她在楼梯上坐着，心都碎了，她在哭。她只是……就像她喘不过气来。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And she wanted a moment to herself because all this togetherness can be really intense, too. And of course, we're there for one another. We're helping each other. But it can just be suffocating, too. And you end up craving your privacy and just a moment for yourself and some air and some space.
她想要一点自己的时间，因为这种所有的在一起也会非常令人窒息。当然，我们是在互相帮助。我们是在互相支持。但这也会令人窒息。最终你会渴望你的隐私，哪怕只是自己的一点时间，一点空气和一点空间。
This is where Chen and her kids spent the week before they're finally released. They were told during that week, it's going to be soon.
这就是 Chen 和她的孩子们最终获释前的一周待的地方。在那一周里，他们被告知，很快了。
They kept saying Friday. Oh, no, it's going to be Saturday. Oh, no, now it's going to be Sunday. I remember thinking to myself, it's not a big deal, like the absurdity of it. It's not a big deal if I stay here one more day.
他们一直说周五。噢，不，是周六。噢，不，现在是周日了。我记得自己在想，没关系，就像它的荒谬之处。如果我再待一天也没关系。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Getting out, I realize I'm going to have to face something very difficult, that I lost Yam and Nadav.
出来后，我意识到我将不得不面对一些非常困难的事情，我失去了 Yam 和 Nadav。
Yam and Nadav, her daughter and husband, of course.
Yam 和 Nadav，当然是她的女儿和丈夫。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And the day of our release came. It was a very nerve wracking day. Saying goodbye to the girls was difficult. They were like, who's going to be released next? Is it going to be the civilians first? The soldiers? I mean, the soldiers kind of understood that it will take a little longer. I mean, they didn't realize it was going to be that long, but they would never imagine they would still be there.
我们的获释日到了。那是令人心碎的一天。和女孩们道别很困难。她们说，谁会是下一个被释放的人？会先是平民吗？士兵？我的意思是，士兵们明白这会花更长的时间。我的意思是，她们没意识到会这么久，但她们永远不会想到她们还会留在那里。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] But there were two other women with you, civilians?
[非英语演讲] 但还有另外两名妇女和你在一起，平民？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Yes, they were wounded, but they're still there. Yes, they're still there.
是的，她们受伤了，但她们仍然在那里。是的，她们还在那里。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
It was a difficult farewell, also deciding what to say to their parents, what not to say to their parents. They ask us to fight for them. They ask us not to forget them, to go to protest, that we speak to their parents. That, we did immediately. They also told us what to say and what not to say. But everything was with the assumption that they would be released right after us. That still hasn't happened. They are still there.
那是一次艰难的道别，也决定了要对她们的父母说什么，不说什么。她们要求我们为她们而战。她们要求我们不要忘记她们，去抗议，和她们的父母交谈。那，我们立刻就做了。她们还告诉我们该说什么和不该说什么。但一切都是建立在她们会在我们之后立刻被释放的假设上的。那仍然没有发生。她们仍然在那里。
Chen and her family were released as part of a deal negotiated by Qatar, Egypt, and the United States, where 80 Israelis, mostly women and children, lots of older people, were swapped for 240 Palestinians, mostly women and children, held in Israeli prisons.
Chen 和她的家人是作为卡塔尔、埃及和美国谈判达成的一项协议的一部分获释的，其中 80 名以色列人（主要是妇女和儿童，许多老人）与被以色列监狱关押的 240 名巴勒斯坦人（主要是妇女和儿童）进行了交换。
Chen's transfer was broadcast on Israeli TV. And the first stages of it look pretty chaotic, actually. There's a random mass of people crowded on some sidewalk. Cars with hostages pull up one after another. Each hostage is ushered down the sidewalk past all this confusion to another waiting car. It was frightening, Chen says.
Chen 的转移在以色列电视上直播。其实它的初期阶段看起来相当混乱。人行道上挤满了随机的一群人。人质车辆一辆接一辆地停下。每个人质都被领下人行道，经过所有这些混乱，被带到另一辆等待的车里。这太可怕了，Chen 说。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
We walk a while from the Hamas vehicles to the Red Cross vehicles. And we're being filmed. It's all staged. And it's like their moment of glory. They're wearing their best uniforms. We never saw these uniforms before.
我们从哈马斯的车辆走到红十字会的车辆。我们在被拍摄。这一切都是安排好的。这就像他们的荣耀时刻。他们穿着最好的制服。我们以前从未见过这些制服。
And I remember asking myself, how did Israel allow this? How could Israel allow our transfer to happen in such a public, exposed place when tons of people were there?
我记得我在问自己，以色列怎么能允许这个？当成千上万的人在那里时，以色列怎么能允许我们的转移在这样一个公共、暴露的地方发生？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
We were scared. We were so scared until the end. We already survived this. We're already about to get released. And they had to make it scary for us, all the way to the end.
我们很害怕。直到最后我们都很害怕。我们已经挺过来了。我们马上就要获释了。他们不得不让它变得可怕，直到最后。
Then, the Red Cross vehicles take off in a convoy and drive all the way to the border.
然后，红十字会的车辆排成车队出发，一路开到边境。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
And then, all of a sudden, like magic, we're being moved to our military. And it was very, very moving.
然后，突然间，像魔法一样，我们被转移到了我们的军方。这非常、非常动人。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
That moment was the saddest happiness of my life.
那一刻是我一生中最悲伤的幸福。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I knew Nadav wouldn't be there to hug me. I just wanted someone to be there and hug me and tell me, that's it. You're safe now, after everything we've gone through.
我知道 Nadav 不会在那里拥抱我。我只是想有人在那里拥抱我，告诉我，就是这样。在我们经历了一切之后，你现在安全了。
Ada, the hostage, who had been an Arabic teacher, also talked in her interview about that moment right at the end of captivity when she finally made it out and reached the Israeli military forces. It got to her in a very different way.
Ada，那个人质，曾是阿拉伯语老师，也在她的采访中谈到了囚禁结束后最终获释并到达以色列军事力量的那一刻。它以一种完全不同的方式触动了她。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
There was a group of officers there. There was a white shining tent with everything you could wish for.
那里有一群军官。有一个闪亮的白色帐篷，有你想要的一切。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I walked in, and they took me in. And I screamed, where were you on the 7th of October? Not that they deserve it because it was not them, but where the hell were their army on the 7th of October? And I started crying, and they caught me at the moment I was falling down. And I'm not one of those fainters. It was a very difficult moment.
我走了进去，他们带我进去了。我尖叫道，10 月 7 日你们在哪里？不是说他们应得的，因为那不是他们，但 10 月 7 日他们的军队到底在哪里？我开始哭泣，在我倒下的那一刻他们抓住了我。我不是那种会昏倒的人。那是非常困难的一刻。
Chen and her family were filmed in the helicopter that brought them home talking to the crew, getting a tour of the cockpit. Chen says it was hard, getting this very respectful treatment, not to think about how this was the same military that she and her kids had been so scared of in Gaza for so long during the airstrikes. These rescuers were in the same army that might have killed them.
Chen 和她的家人在带他们回家的直升机上被拍摄到与机组人员交谈，参观驾驶舱。Chen 说这很困难，获得这种非常尊重的对待，禁不住会想到这和她和孩子们在加沙期间由于空袭而感到害怕的竟然是同一支军队。这些救援者属于可能杀了他们的同一支军队。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Did you say anything about it?
[非英语演讲] 你说了什么吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
I started talking about when I first came back, because when I was in Gaza, I promised myself that I would talk about it, that I would talk about that complexity. But then you come back and they tell you, don't talk about it as much with the media, not with the international media, of course, because it's not a good look.
我刚回来时就开始谈论这件事，因为当我在加沙时，我向自己保证过我会谈论它，我会谈论那种复杂性。但当你回来时，他们告诉你，不要在媒体上多谈，当然不要在国际媒体上谈，因为它看起来不好。
And you see here how hard it is. You see people who did a bunch of operations in the military and got to very senior positions, and they're not able-- it's like they can't-- they're unable to come and just say, we're sorry. We're sorry for what you went through on the 7th when you were inside your shelter. We're sorry that we bombed in Gaza when you were there with your kids.
在这里你会看到它有多难。你会看到在军队中执行过多次行动并达到很高职位的人，他们无法——就像他们不能——他们无法走出来说，我们很抱歉。我们很抱歉你们在 7 日待在避难所时经历了这一切。我们很抱歉我们在你们带着孩子在那里时轰炸了加沙。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
Margalit Moses, the woman you heard earlier who was held in the tunnels the entire time, was released two days before Chen. She got invited this summer by Prime Minister Netanyahu to meet with him and some other released hostages. She wrote this letter as her reply.
Margalit Moses，你之前听到的那个一直被关在地道里的女性，在 Chen 回家前两天获释。今年夏天她受内塔尼亚胡总理邀请与他和一些获释的人质会面。她写了这封信作为回复。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
"Hello, Mr. Netanyahu."
“你好，内塔尼亚胡先生。”
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
"Thank you for the invitation, but I will not participate in a meeting for the sake of photos and public relations while my friends are rotting in Hamas tunnels in Gaza. With my own eyes, I saw them alive in captivity, and now, due to their second abandonment since October 7, we are receiving them in coffins.
“感谢您的邀请，但我不会为了照片和公关参加会议，而我的朋友们正烂在加沙的哈马斯地道里。我亲眼看到她们在被囚禁中还活着，现在，由于她们自 10 月 7 日以来的第二次被遗弃，我们正用棺材接她们回来。
In light of reports that you have thwarted yet another deal to release the captives, I see no reason to attend a meeting with somebody who has demonstrated through his actions that the release of the captives is not a priority and who is abandoning them to their death. I would be happy to meet you at the welcoming event for the 109 captives upon their return to their families."
鉴于有报道称您又一次阻止了一项释放被俘人员的协议，我看不到有任何理由与一个用行动表明释放被俘人员不是优先事项，并任由她们死亡的人会面。如果 109 名被俘人员在返回家人身边时举行欢迎活动，我很乐意与您会面。”
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演讲]
"Thank you."
“谢谢。”
Margalit Moses.
Margalit Moses。
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis, Diane Wu, Yael Even Or, and me, with editing help from Nancy Updike, based on interviews from the Israeli podcast, Echad Beyom, a production of N12.
我们今天的节目由 Dana Chivvis、Diane Wu、Yael Even Or 和我制作，Nancy Updike 协助编辑，基于以色列播客《Echad Beyom》（N12 出品）的采访。
The staff of Echad Beyom who produced these interviews are Lee Naim, Shira Erell, Rom Atik, Yair Bashan, and Guy Enbar. Our Hebrew interpreters were Yael Evan Or, Amira Joelson, and Miriam Kaplan.
制作这些采访的《Echad Beyom》工作人员是 Lee Naim、Shira Erell、Rom Atik、Yair Bashan 和 Guy Enbar。我们的希伯来语口译员是 Yael Evan Or、Amira Joelson 和 Miriam Kaplan。
The people who put together our show today include Bim Adewunmi, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Hany Hawasly, Chana Joffe-Walt, Valerie Kipnis, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
今天参与制作我们节目的还有 Bim Adewunmi、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Emmanuel Dzotsi、Hany Hawasly、Chana Joffe-Walt、Valerie Kipnis、Henry Larson、Seth Lind、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Ike Sriskandarajah、Laura Starcheski、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala、Marisa Robertson-Textor、Matt Tierney 和 Nancy Updike。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Noa Yachot, Daria Shualy, Etgar Keret, and Sam [? Klein. ?] Also thanks today to the rest of the Echad Beyom staff-- Elad Simchayoff, Adi Hetsroni, Danielle Shahar, and Danny Nudelman.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。你可以完全免费收听我们超过 800 集的档案。《这是美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 发送到公共广播电台。我是 Ira Glass。下周带来更多《这是美国生活》的故事。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。您可以免费在线收听我们超过 800 集的节目存档。《This American Life》由公共广播交流平台 PRX 发送至各个公共广播电台。我是 Ira Glass。下周将带来更多《This American Life》的故事。